[Music]
i gotta fix the [ __ ] lights our party
lights aren't on yeah i forgot to
well because i gotta plug this in yeah
because the um
for some reason they make like a loud
like the fan inside the light like makes
a really loud noise
what the hell so i what are you doing i
don't know yeah
so i usually like keep it off and then
sometimes i forget like right until
right before streaming because sometimes
i'm recording other things and i don't
want that fan noise in the background
it was just turned off whoo
well the lights on though you have to
turn the light off so you can see the
lasers better
yeah because it does it goes back hi
everybody mango says i'm still drunk
from yesterday
yeah we kind of are too no well no not
really we went out
we went out to uh memento mori last
night
and we hadn't been for a long time you
had a good night
it was fun actually had a good night not
a hell of a lot of people obviously but
it's not a ghost town down there though
it's all right i mean it's a monday
night so
i mean there were more people around for
being a monday night than i thought
um i want you to come this way i don't
know i don't know what you should do
the um you want a wig you want to do
anything with that
somebody was asking about have we ever
considered to do a cooking stream
yeah we have yeah we have considered
that lots of times yeah a lot of
technical problems though
with it um you have to have the lighting
and the photography has to be just right
or all food looks like [ __ ]
yeah a lot of the food photography
doesn't even involve taking pictures of
food
it's not even food a lot of a lot of
it's [ __ ] like for instance vanilla
ice cream is
mashed potatoes it's almost always
crisco yeah
just they if you were to see what it was
they were really photograph and then
they touch it up
if you were to see what they were really
photographing you know it's it's
inedible some of stuff's even painted
but um i always i always heard that when
they do
you know how they do like the
photographs on the front of cereal boxes
of like the cereal with the milk pouring
in it that that's always like watered
down elmer's glue
yeah i don't know if that's true i just
heard that
so to do a cooking stream we'd have to
have the lighting and we'd have to have
good enough cameras to do that it's not
really worth it you know if
it's not the main focus of the show
that's the way i was looking at it
i mean i just challenge you to find a
good
video of somebody making a pizza and
taking a picture of that pizza
uh just with a regular and then everyone
being like oh that looks delicious yeah
yeah you know
just it looks like it's like [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
so you know you got oh this thing tastes
great then you the audience is looking
at it and goes man that thing looks like
[ __ ]
i don't want to make it
all right so yeah this might not be like
a super long stream today because i'm
really really tired i mean
you know like i said we went out last
night i had a good time but
and i did get a little bit of sleep i
slept about an hour
maybe an hour hour and a half later than
usual which is a big deal for me
but um yeah i'm starting to fade it's
like three o'clock in the afternoon
and i still and i still have like a
graphic design job i have to do
so this is a movie that i think you just
maybe
came in like at the end of it or
something like that i
had this seems like it's not really
getting much um
much play i heard about it it was on one
of those
um you know 50 best horror movies on
hulu or whatever like one of those lists
because i keep track of those because
they update them i think it's a v club
or something like that they update them
like every month
and um so this was one of the ones that
came up kind of in the lower reaches and
i was like oh it's got that kid
uh joe keary who played steve on
stranger things
so i was like oh what you know all right
that's and it's
billed as a horror comedy or horror
thriller or
um comedy thriller yeah what did i say i
don't know but um
so i decided well that sounds kind of
fun so i decided to watch it now
this seems like it's gotten kind of
mixed reviews a lot of the horror
channels i watched um
really liked it there was a lot of [ __ ]
i liked about this um
basically what the story is joe kiri
is playing this kind of 20-something kid
with the unfortunate name of kurt kunkel
which sounds like [ __ ] and cankle and
then
like combined and i was like hold on one
second amy williams said uh
she heard about this channel on another
channel so she decided to check it out i
don't know really find out what channel
you heard about
oh wow i wonder what it is maybe it's
conspiracy
they talk us about it about us a lot um
but yeah so all right so kurt kunkel
and he has this um kind of lame
little live stream thing that he does
kind of like
it's a lot lamer than ours and uh i
think it's called kurt's world 96
or something like that and he is
desperate for
followers and desperate to become viral
he wants to be
like this big influencer celebrity but
he's really not um achieving that goal
it's like he has something like
20 followers or something like that i
can't remember it's like some pitiful
amount
now it turns out that he has there's a
kid in his
neighborhood like a friend of his named
bobby who he used to babysit
when he was little and bobby is a really
really popular
influencer and it's like making all this
kind of money so there's kind of some
jealousy going on
so kurt in his desperation to become
internet famous
decides that what he's going to do he
works for a company called spree which
is essentially like
lyft or uber it's rideshare and he
decides that he's going to
install cameras all over his car
and have all the water bottles in the
back and have them all be poisoned and
start
killing people that are like that are
you know doing the ride share
and he's gonna live stream it and that's
how he's gonna get famous
now so he starts doing this and
it's actually kind of working out you
know what i mean and he's it's
you know but he's not getting as many
followers as he thinks it does
and then as the movie goes on like [ __ ]
just starts getting crazier and crazier
and crazy like
it's not even poisoning people anymore
it's like [ __ ] the car flips like
cops get shot
it's just it's a whole [ __ ] thing
like people get [ __ ] run over
it's just it's nuts so the thing that i
liked about this
i liked um i liked
joe keary in this i really really liked
him on stranger things because i've
you know he really kind of like evolved
as a character he kind of started as
this douchey
kind of jock type person but then like
he became one of the most beloved
characters on the show like as his kind
of character grew
this is a very very different character
from him he's essentially playing
a dorky he's kind of dorky and pathetic
but he's also
kind of charming in a weird way but also
he's a sociopath
obviously and all he cares about is
getting attention
and he doesn't give a [ __ ] that he's
just killing people to get attention you
know what i'm saying yeah amy said she
heard about us on movie central equals
m.c
oh i've never heard a movie central i
haven't either they must be listening to
it i don't think
i have to go check movies
now i'm going to have to go check that
out i mean i might have seen that
because a lot of times what i'll do
is i mean i have a lot of youtube video
like channels that i follow
but a lot of times when i'm just doing
research or i want to watch movie
reviews or something like that i just
kind of like watch them and i'm not
really like paying attention to what the
name of the channel is
yeah maybe that's i forget that we that
our movie reviews actually have any
reach but then i went back and looked at
our old
[ __ ] logan's run review and we had
like one of the number one reviews on
logan's run
that seems to be like one of our most
popular and that's one of the first ones
we did
yeah maybe just add audio quality maybe
just because not that many people had
reviewed it
the right time i guess so on yeah
got in on the right time on logan's run
yeah i think some of it is because we
analyzed logan's run a lot brought up a
lot of stuff about it
yeah you know and i kind of had a theory
that maybe uh
the the the the city had popped open and
the computer destroyed itself and
found out that you could survive outside
i thought it was like an arc
yeah and there were some people that
read it says that
says the book isn't anything like that
but as the movie that may be possible
because the movie departed from the book
anyway a lot
i always meant to read that book i need
to like put that on my on my tbr list
yeah in the book it was not an enclosed
city it was it was a whole world and i
think there was
i think there might have been a colony
on
on another world too i think mars might
have been colonized and there was stuff
going on on mars too
i forgot but it's uh more like blade
runner
yeah in the book
okay but throwing this [ __ ] down side
tracker
but trying to make a complete show and i
didn't see this movie yeah i think you
just saw the end like i said
you know so um so i really really liked
his character i guess it shows
like what range he's got because he kind
of portrayed
um you know this character that was just
getting crazier and crazier
but he was still kind of charming in a
way and also you know kind of dorky even
though he was like kind of desperate you
know
so i think he was so he was kind of like
the highlight and uh some of the
violence especially like as it goes on
it gets really really crazy and it's you
know just kind of a really really
funny like some of the [ __ ] i just
[ __ ] laughed out loud you know what i
mean because
it was just i was just like holy [ __ ]
they [ __ ] did that but
so that was good there was a couple
things that
i feel like maybe okay now i will tell
you one thing because this is
essentially
a social media satire it's satirical
um in the sense that they're kind of
making fun
of these of influencer culture a little
bit and
the lengths that people will go to to
get people to watch them
and um you know it also kind of parodies
because a lot of the thing it's
i don't really want to call it found
footage but the whole thing is taken
from his car cameras
um you know his stream on his phone like
[ __ ] like that so it's sort of
presented like in that kind of way you
know like a lot of those kind of
internet based movies
where you know everything is uh you know
is footage from one place or another
and a lot of times you can see like the
live chat logs like going around the
side and it's like it was when he
murders people everyone just thinks it's
lame because they think it's fake and
all this other kind of stuff so
it's kind of making fun of that a little
bit um but i will say
that i don't know this movie
is very what's the word i want to use
spazzy
okay it's really spazzy um it's really
frenetic like it's very
early 20s influencer kind of per it's
you know what i mean so it's very very
quick paced it's very kind of i don't
know it's spazzy
so if you think that's going to bother
you because a couple of times i was just
like no i know i'm old and everything
but i was just kind of like man
chill out a second it's like
everything's like flying around and
there's like [ __ ] screens and chat
logs going all over the place and i was
just like i think i'm getting a migraine
but yeah so it's it's a little bit
spazzy so just know that
also there's kind of a side plot
i don't know if i'd call it a side plot
but um
at one point he picks up like he's
killing off
most of his you know some of his ride
share people like he doesn't make them
he doesn't like shoot them in the face
or anything not until like later
but if they drink the poison water then
he's just like oh they're dead and then
he just goes and like gets rid of their
body somehow or whatever
but he picks up and most of the people
like are dicks so it's like you don't
really feel that bad at least at first
but so he picks up this one woman who is
a comedian
and she's kind of well known she's kind
you know in she's internet famous i
guess like
she's a big influencer and whatnot and
he picks her up and she's kind of funny
at first and then he kind of gets
obsessed with her because she has all
these followers
so he kind of starts i don't know if
stalking is the right word but
he's trying to like desperately trying
to get her to
mention him or to follow him and [ __ ]
like that
and she's i like that actress and i
liked her as a character
but the thing about it and i think cody
said this on
on his uh channel his his horror review
channel he really likes this movie too
but he's like
the thing about it is that if you're
gonna have a character in the movie
that's a comedian and they're supposed
to be this big famous community they
have millions of followers
they should at least be funny and
when she was doing because they showed
like parts of her stand up and stuff
like that and it wasn't really all that
funny
so i'm just like you know that that was
the only thing like she was kind of
funny and like snarky and smart ass and
stuff like that like when she was in the
car
like and she was interacting with with
him and like the other guy that was in
there
but when they showed like parts of her
stand-up set later on i think that part
just went on too long because
she wasn't like as funny as you'd think
that she would be
being that popular i went over and
checked that movie channel mc that amy
williams was talking about that
channel's got four million [ __ ] subs
holy crap i must be you sure that that
channel talked about us
something must be there must be some
kind of breakdown into communications
movie channel mc is our little
subs and it looks corporate as hell i
just i i have a hard time believing that
maybe somebody that works there likes us
i don't know if somebody works there let
us
look very corporate although i didn't
check any of the videos but you know
maybe yeah
maybe three four million [ __ ] sub
we'll be there one day i noticed this
morning that we had broken
ten thousand three hundred i think we're
at ten thousand three hundred and one
i think when i looked when i looked this
morning sounds like he had a little
boost there because
i looked at i looked at it um just a
couple days ago and it was
it was ten thousand two hundred yeah so
we're gaining faster
yeah i think we got um yeah they said
they talked about us last night what'd
they say about us last night
it's like these idiots
probably talking [ __ ] about me fall
asleep on the show getting drunk
fall asleep on the show wait did you
ever fall asleep on the show no
i don't come close though yeah i
remember you coming close a few times
we've been like so drunk that
i've been so drunk by the end of the
stream like the long streams that i
can't remember if i turned it off or not
and then i wake up like three hours
later and go oh no i was like did i turn
that off did i
did i [ __ ] it up but uh yeah that's just
we just do a homemade show
it's just a little small crowd so you
know we we played to a very small
audience we didn't really
plan on we when we started we didn't
even really take this all that seriously
yeah and i mean we we do but we don't
yeah i mean in a way that we just want
it to be fun we want it to be fun for us
yeah and we feel like it'll be if it's
fun for us then it'll be fun for you
guys
that was kind of [ __ ] we listened to
yeah and i was just you know
so it's like if other people don't like
that the first year though i gotta say
we were just [ __ ] around with it i
mean but you had a lot of
work because it was just collages we
didn't have that video because we didn't
have a video component
yeah but we realized it's so much easier
just to do [ __ ] video component for
it that's what everybody else is doing
yeah so we just fell into line with what
everybody else is doing
and yeah like you said it is a lot
easier because i had to sit there and go
through and it took like [ __ ] hours
and hours and hours like to find
yeah we don't have to scroll through
them we don't have stage fright i don't
care if
nobody really cares you know [ __ ]
jenny and i don't care if you see us
so yeah we're just like man let's just
go ahead and [ __ ]
get a webcam i had stage fright a little
bit at the beginning but not bad not bad
though i didn't really have it just well
yeah but you grew up you did
theater and all that other kind of stuff
i didn't really do that i
sang in a choir but that was not that
wasn't singing by myself i was like in a
big group you know what i mean
yeah having [ __ ] people watching in a
digital world over a camera that's
nothing like in front of performance in
front of a live well
that's a lot more [ __ ] pressure and
you got to do everything in one take
and you're [ __ ] singing and doing
musicals and [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
dancing
and uh yeah tell you what make you
popular with the ladies but
boy was a lot of pressure although you
get a high off of it's like cocaine
you start getting better and better
especially after like the first two
shows
and then all of a sudden you're in this
you're in a groove
you can go in there and put on this
[ __ ] whole act and do your role and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] and have a lot of fun with it
yeah
yeah i think i mean yeah because on here
it's not like
you know it's not an act yeah and plus
if we [ __ ] up we can just go oops we
[ __ ] up
yeah and then just keep on going you
know what i mean it's not like
i'm a ballet dancer and i follow my ass
or something like that yeah there's
nothing like
louis said he subscribed when we were
only 500 subs
yeah i remember like some of y'all have
been around for a really long time
because i remember y'all commenting on
stuff like way back
back in the day yeah um yeah
since you're not you're not like a
regular you're you're a new listener you
want us
you want to see us on our on our [ __ ]
main show on
saturdays and wednesdays we're uh we're
doing it this is wednesday too right
yeah tomorrow
we're gonna just do yeah we're gonna
start doing it every wednesday we're
gonna do just a regular
open live stream we talk to the audience
and we
everybody drinks and uh it'll i think
we'll probably have like a
it's a couple generalized topics we'll
talk about
we'll bring up that way you know i mean
there's no dead air but there usually
isn't dead air if we're streaming
yeah that's the whole god damn thing
last wednesday i did i was just like i
have no idea what she was
in the show i had to pull her off she's
looking at jenny i know that's what was
so funny about it because usually i
i'm like so tired and it's like i don't
want to end it but that last time i was
having such a good time yeah she didn't
want to end the show
i was like well because i guess like the
regular show i have fun
on that too but i always kind of feel
like um you know i was like man i got to
get through like all my notes
at least you know i want to hit this
point that point you know i at least
want to have like some of the
information that i wanted to convey
like so i have to keep going back to my
notes being like oh man we have those
like this much left to talk about
but on the freeform one it doesn't
matter
you know um i got some music picked out
that's a lot better
than the last one but i'm still worried
about i'm worried there might be some
copyright issues i don't know
other people were streaming it but i
don't know if they had permission to i
mean some
some yeah some channels have permission
to do it i don't know but hate
to live stream something and have some
background music going
and then have the whole thing [ __ ]
pulled and demonetized just because one
of those
songs it was copyrighted yeah in a lot
of ways it's kind of like if you're
going to put
music in the background it's better to
just go to a site
yeah that is specifically for that and
like you know that you can get away with
using it yeah
maybe we'll either do that or we'll in
the background we'll just have some rain
and thunk
thunder and lightning [ __ ] going on
in the back and maybe just some
ambient music that's generic yeah wow
i'll yeah i'll have to find some find
something that's like that just to hold
us over until we
find it good because i like to i want to
have a little bit of mood music in the
background
yeah you know i kind of like to set the
tone of the show i kind of like
you know like rain sounds and [ __ ] like
that because i listen to a lot of those
you know scary stories channels like
they're a whole bunch of different ones
and um some of them some of them don't
have anything in the background but some
of them have like a little like rain or
one of them has like a little fireplace
like crackling so it's you're like
you're sitting around the fire and
somebody's telling you ghost stories
that's pretty cool but um
yeah so what else was i saying about
this movie oh yeah so how you
approach this movie is gonna be now
it's on hulu um i think mango said that
on that in the uk
it's on shutter it's not on shutter here
i don't think um i haven't looked today
but it's on hulu and i think it's also
on amazon prime
uh david arquette is in this too if if
that's any
consolation but um it's like i said how
you feel about it is going to be
contingent upon how do you feel about
you know social media influencers and
watching them even though it's kind of
making fun of them and it's satirical
it is still kind of because some parts
of it i found like a little bit
annoying you know what i mean just
because
you know it's it's just like it's a lot
um
you know because i'm kind of an old
person but um i'm just saying
it's a lot i was just i was just kind of
like there's scrolling things over here
and there's like a window here and a
window here and a windows
just like dude i'm getting a headache
but um you know but it was just like
every now and then
but yeah there was a couple things i
didn't like about it but on the whole um
it's actually pretty fun so you know
check it out if it's something that
you're into like i said i didn't see a
huge amount of
reviews on this because i think it only
came out to vod
i think it was at sundance like the
beginning of last year
and then i just came out on vod like in
august or something like that
and i just saw it on some list some
place that were like hey this decent
horror that's on hulu
so i'm kind of going through and
watching all those because i just got
hulu not too long ago
and uh yeah so this one wasn't bad at
all
you know you done i'm done
me too i'm sleepy all right man i was
going to try and go for a walk this
afternoon because i slept so late
and go this morning but then i was like
man i don't even [ __ ] stay awake i
don't think i could stay awake long
enough to walk anywhere it was good to
get out of the house to
go downtown go to the club i mean there
were some people out
uh yeah not a [ __ ] ton it's good
you know florida's florida's in good
shape
compared to a lot of the rest of the
country these lockdowns a friend of mine
from new york was [ __ ]
he's he's in town he said just new york
is just [ __ ] right now
he said just [ __ ] nothing but just
like gunshots every [ __ ] few minutes
he's got
some app on his phone where the shooting
shootings are happening it's just
[ __ ] everybody's leaving it's going
like it says it's a ghost town in
certain areas
says it's like it was but he was he's
from that area he says it's going back
to
like it was in 1981 you know like we'll
see
yeah we'll see i should tell you this
just got to iron itself out man i'm not
feeling good about it
well now but you know we'll see how it
goes we're going to talk you guys
through this we'll see
motivation like i said just just cheer
everybody up man yeah but it was feeling
it
i can't do [ __ ] about [ __ ] you can't do
anything about it anyway i can't do she
can only control what you control
yeah exactly but uh you know the deal
people
yeah so uh so tomorrow
at 5 00 pm eastern we go and do
one of our fun party streams yeah we'll
do a party stream no no we gotta just
call down
a party stream
that makes a lot more sense well you put
a lamborghini will you put a lampshade
on your head
you got wigs if you get drunk enough you
might
[ __ ] robotic fish i think that one is
not flopping
anymore it'll be charged huh no it's
it's charged it's just i think the
little uh
the little floppy thing the hinge became
on
so that's how hard pookie was playing
with it she figured out
i think the orange one is out there and
i think that one probably so it probably
has like a
quick detach thing where you can't break
it that's cool yeah that's what i
thought
so she must have been [ __ ] with it
and like broke it it's probably fixable
i hope so all right so we will see you
guys tomorrow evening
for the party stream uh thanks for
dropping by
have a good rest of your day the elkies
man but i know
i'm gonna try not to drink tonight i
drank a lot last night a lot of
grapefruit vodka it was good though
all right we'll see you guys just not
doing it yeah see his tail is not
flopping
she must she pulled it apart i think
yeah i'll fix it all right
all right we'll see you guys tomorrow
bye